hey everyone
welcome to another video by simplylearn
i am sure you must have watched our
previous videos on blueprism
if you haven't watched them already i
would suggest you to go through
tutorials on blueprism
blueprism is a global leader in
intelligent enterprise automation
transforming the way employees work by
making it simple for individuals to
automate operations
blue prism helps enterprises improve
operational efficiency
and agility if you are planning to
attend an interview for an rpa
or blue prism developer role here is a
comprehensive list of the most
frequently asked
blue prism interview questions with
answers
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and clicked on the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started we will first look at
the beginner level interview questions
what is blue prism blue prism is a
software
that develops enterprise robotic process
automation
allowing businesses to automate complex
end-to-end operations
blueprism developed the virtual
workforce platform concept
and works on the enterprise robotic
process automation platform that is
strong
highly scalable secure and reliable
blueprism software complements
standardity solutions by utilizing an
agile virtual workforce that follows
rule-based business process
and interacts with system the same way
users do
blue prisms rp software solution
automates tasks that would otherwise be
carried out manually by humans
or through significant customization of
current i.t systems
which would result in a higher level of
automation with significantly lesser
investment and faster deployment
explain the different types of tabs in
blue prism dashboard
there are six types of tabs in blue
prism the first tab is
home the homepage includes many charts
that provide information on the
blueprism database
blueprism studio is a critical component
through which we build actual automation
actions
with studio we can automate a process
build a process using flow
add logic calculations and intelligence
without writing any code
we can also drag in actions calculations
loops and more
in studio we can connect the blocks in
preferred order we can use
intelligent skills from digital exchange
the studios are divided into two
categories object studio
and process studio control room
the control room is the key
administrative point in blue prism
where it handles the control monitoring
execution
and scheduling of process executions on
dispersed bots
the control room assigns the processes
to digital workers
users can quickly start a process by
dragging it onto a resource
analytics blueprism analytics is a
module
that allows you to see data graphically
in the form of charts
such as pie chart bar chart column gauge
and line
releases the release manager is used to
manage configuration package
import and export between multiple
blueprism settings
system administrators use the system tab
to manage users
explain the features of blue prism
provides intelligent execution
technology organizations
can instruct the autonomous engine on
process priorities
feed amounts of work and leave it to run
without human involvement
responding to systems business scenario
and change in priority
robots like humans can be used to do
tasks based on sla volume
and priority and adjust and change robot
allocation dynamically without human
intervention
high security a software robot securely
locks into an application
and manipulates the presentation layer
in the same manner a person would
but in a controlled non-invasive
environment ensuring that the
application's integrity is never
affected
on premises or in the cloud on-premises
or hybrid enterprise deployment
provisioned in a public or a private
cloud the robots are existing and
running
any operation set in blue prism can be
conducted on
any number of robots in the virtual
workforce
microsoft sql server blue prism is built
on microsoft.net framework
it is technologically flexible working
across the other platforms
and technologies such as a mainframe
windows app wpf app
java sap exchange and many more
scalability blue prism is object
oriented allowing for a rapid
scalability
by utilizing reusable items and
libraries
analytics and reporting provides high
quality data that can be used to produce
relevant bi and mi reporting and provide
inline process statistics and real-time
operational insights by capturing each
step
work use work use provides a q-centric
approach for dynamically controlling the
number of resources
or robots operating against a given
queue at any given time
what is a process studio the process
studio is created as a diagram that
looks much like a common business flow
diagram
process studio allows the company rit to
design
build edit and test process made out of
reusable blue prism elements
as the library of business object grows
actions can be scheduled and controlled
in the process layer
the top tier of the blue prism
architecture process studio provides a
similar interface to object studio
and allows you to sequence and test
business logic control loops variables
and
object calls invisible business flow
what is object studio object studio is
the design canvas on which blue prism
robot is programmed to conduct the
fundamental
system activities that serve as a
foundation of process
the presentation layer which provides a
library of elements
to operate quickly models and validates
the target desktop application
we have several types of activities
within the object such as modular
application to spy the elements
initialize page and cleanup page
what is control room in blue prism
control room allows businesses or id
services to schedule perform and control
processes
blue prism platform administrators use
the control room interface to monitor
and review the status of connected
runtime resources in the production
environment
the interface also allows for manual
process start and stop
automated process schedule setting and
extensive management information
and dig downs into blue prism task
queues in production environment
process are run from a control room from
control room
processors do not run on a version of
blue prism that is local to your desktop
but is instead run on an external
resource known as digital workers
which can be found in the resource area
what is the environment variable the
environment variable is a type of
exposure in data item
in which data item value is easily
changed without using the processor
object
it is available in the system tab under
the process section
which are the data types available in
blue prism
data items can store a range of data
types though each data item within a
process must be assigned
a specific data type to store the data
types available in blue prism
are as follows date flag date time
number text password time
image and binary
explain weight stage weight stage
enables business objects to pause and
wait for an application to load
or a condition to be met before
continuing
weight conditions can be applied to
weight stages to evaluate whether a
condition exists within a specific
period
the weight condition produces a flag
value determining which of the two
branches
the logic will flow down it is best to
include a conditional wage stage at the
start of every object diagram
it is possible to set multiple weight
conditions for a weight stage
by adding additional rows into the
action area
the weight stage simultaneously checks
each weight condition it doesn't require
all weight conditions to be met even if
one condition is met
the path will be determined if none of
the weight conditions are met
the action will time out
explain the benefits of blue prism
automated speed
days and weeks to automate a process in
blue prism that would take months and
years to automate using a standard
automation methodologies
less expense robots are programmed with
the business rules of repetitive
clerical duties
and deployed to drive existing
applications eliminating the requirement
for costly integration and process
redesign expertise
improved performance small specialist
ability within the it department
collaborates with the robotic workforce
to train them
manage referrals and continuously
enhance their operational performance
secure the robotic automation platform
is secure
audited and governed within the
governance iit corridor
the usage of software robots invariably
increases
compliance with applicable data
standards and confidentiality
scalable because the software robots
operate in a virtualized environment
they can be rapidly scaled up and down
based on the demand
what is exceptional handling in blue
prism
exceptional handling is critical part of
any blue prism solution
an exception is a problem that arises
during the execution of a process
or an object when errors are encountered
in blue prism it generates exceptions
the managing of exceptions in unattended
automation is defined as exception
handling
it ensures that defaults can be
automatically fixed if possible
or that they are easily identified
repairable by system administrators
or that they can be forwarded for human
completion if necessary
exception handling success is determined
by how well it is implemented throughout
the development phase
explain the different stages of
exception handling the different stages
of exceptional handling are
discovery resume and exception in
recovery stage
begins a block for handling exceptions
in resume stage it ends a block for
handling exceptions
in exception stage explicitly rises an
exception in the execution of a process
or an object
explain the applications of blueprism
blueprism's rpa software is used in the
following process types
rules based processing using a
structured digital inputs such as credit
card activation or fraud detection
transactional processing that is
repeated such as sim swaps or invoicing
processing
transaction quantities that are high
such as building or new handset order
processing
issues with process adherence quality
such as policy renewables or policy
migrations
complex mission critical procedures such
as pension redemptions and financial
reconciliation changes in demand or
backlogs
such as new product launches using hr
onboarding or the introduction of new
online product where no
integration exists
now let us look at the intermediate
level interview questions
what is an application modeler which are
the different types of spying modes
present in it
a business object aims to integrate with
an application
to make the business accessible for use
by a blue prism process to create the
integration you must connect the
business object to the application
by creating an application modeler this
can be achieved via application modeler
within the object studio
the process of creating a logical
representation of an application
by identifying and capturing elements
from the user interface of the
application
is called spying the four different
types of spying modes are as follows
win32 mode html mode accessibility mode
and region mode
explain circular paths in blue prism
blue prism is designed to automate
repetitive work and inclusion of
circular paths
looping process diagrams enables some
steps to be repeated over and over again
components that are essential for
building circular path
which will allow a process flow to loop
through
then progress to the end once the loop
limit is met
components that are essential for
building a circular path which will
allow a process flow to loop through
then process to the end once the loop
limit is met
explain the types of exceptions in blue
prism
the three types of exceptions in blue
prism are internal exception
internal exceptions come based on our
missing mandatory data in stages
system exceptions these exceptions will
occur based on the internet is down
or our bot needs internet or any system
failures
business exceptions these exceptions are
not really exceptions
they are based on the business rules we
are creating the exceptions
we need to fire manually through the bot
what are work queues our queue is a list
that may be configured internally to
help a process manage its workload
a process may use numerous work use and
work you may be shared by multiple
processes if necessary work queues are
created
and configured in the workflow area of
system manager
this is where work use can be provided
with a name and a key name
the key name directly correlates to a
column name in the collection stage
used within a process to add new items
to a work queue
explain the stages in process studio
decision stage decision stage have two
branches coming out of them
enabling a process to split into two
separate paths
they are used to evaluate the result of
an expression as either true or
false in blue prism these outcomes are
known as flags
calculation stage calculation stage
use expressions to calculate values
these can be numerical or made using
values such as
text dates etc they are dependent on
data items to store results and can work
with data items to perform calculations
data items data item acts as a
placeholder for values
such as numbers text and dates
they can give a meaningful names like
user name
email id and employed around the process
diagram data item is like a variable
explain process validation
the validation button opens the process
validation window for diagnosing
issues the validation window categorizes
issues
as errors warning and advice it
identifies the type of action that
should be taken to resolve them
and whether they are repairable by blue
prism
validation checks the basic construction
of process diagram
but it is not capable of analyzing the
logic the responsibility is always on
the user
explain collections and loops in blue
prism
collection stage provides process
diagram the ability to hold multiple
values together
the values stored within the collection
states are accessed one row at a time
using a loop stage to move forward
through the rows
loop stages is divided into two parts
loop start and loop end
explain business objects the purpose of
business object is to provide an
interface to capture the functionality
of an application
business objects are used as a part of
process solution
and can be thought of as a separate
layer of process the tasks within a
business objects are separated out in
different pages known as actions
each action relates to a particular
interaction with an application
and a process will use whichever of this
action it requires
in any order to perform a specific task
within the application
explain the difference between process
and object studio
in process studio the development tool
creates a diagram
that resembles a flow diagram object
studio
creates objects graphically by the
development tool
proso studio has alert stage only object
studio has
read write navigate code and wait stage
process studio consists of main page
only
object studio consists of initialize and
cleanup page
resource studio interacts with the
object studio and control room
object studio interacts with external
applications
launch an application modeler is not
available in process studio
but whereas in object studio it is
available
explain throttles and unconditional
weights in blue prism
weight stages can be used without any
conditions
with the timeout serving as a pause to
delay the flow through the diagram
this is referred as throttling
throttling allows some extra time to
accommodate the variable performance
speed of an application
it is best practice to include
throttling at the beginning of every
action page
that interacts within the application
explain the input and output parameters
in blueprism
input and output parameters are used to
transmit values between the process
diagram and the business object
action business objects any value that
is required to input into the elements
of an application
should be passed down from a process via
an input parameter
the business object should only retain
the information passed down to it
for as long as it takes to complete the
interaction
end stage on the lower page can use
output parameters to transmit a value
up to a page reference stage on an upper
page
now let us look at some of the advanced
level blue prism interview questions
what is a scheduler and how to configure
it
the blue prism tool allows to execute
process at a specified times
and repeat their execution at different
intervals it is termed as scheduler
the blue prism tool allows you to run
process at specific times
and repeat them at different intervals
this is known as scheduler
configure scheduler in the system tab by
clicking on the scheduler option
after we configure the scheduler we need
to click on the check box
to activate it
explain release manager in blue prism
blueprism release manager enables users
to compile
all of the components of a blue prism
solution into a package
including processes business objects and
work use
and schedules calendars tiles and
dashboards
to export a solution package a release
must be created by
right clicking package overview and
selecting new package
a release is a snapshot of a state of
each of the components within a package
at a particular moment in time
how to create object in object studio
here are the steps to create object in
object studio
launch the blue prism software and open
the studio tab
right click on the objects and select
create object
then enter a name for new business
object enter the description which is
optional
and finally it will create an object in
objects list
so let's jump into blueprism software
and create object
so after launching the blue prism
software
go to studio
go to objects right click objects and
click on create object
enter the name of the object so i'll
enter
object demo
after entering the name click on next
and enter the description
which is optional and click on finish
and here you can see the object is
created in the object list
that is how you create an object in the
object studio
explain the concept of exceptional
bubbling since
exceptions can occur at any point
throughout a process solution
whenever an exception occurs it will
always move up towards the main page of
the process to the highest layer of the
process solution
an exception will continue to bubble up
from an action in business object
and then through the hierarchy of pages
within the calling process
until it reaches the page that contains
a recovery logic
at this point the exception will be
handled
if the main page of the highest layer of
the process solution
does not have logic to handle the error
then an error message window will appear
when running in process studio
the same error occurs when running a
process in control room the process will
terminate
how to import vbo in blue prism
the first step is go to blue prism
studio and click on file
and click on import then the import
release dialog box opens
click on browse navigate to program
files in c
drive in program files go to blue prism
limited
then to blue prism automate and open
vbevo
from there you can double click and
select the object
demonstrate the working of an email
automation in blue prism
first we'll create a new process then
we'll perform some of the actions
in which we will use action stage data
item and collection stage
then after performing all the required
actions finally we will go to our mail
inbox and check if we have received the
mail
so we will jump into blue prism software
and see how to import
and bbo in blue prism and
see the working of email automation in
blue prism
let's go to studio
the very first step is to import email
pop3
smdp business object to import that go
to file
go to import process object
and go to browse you have to go to the
folder where blue prism software is
installed
in my device it's installed in c
go to local disk c go to program files
and go to blue prism limited
blue prism automate here scroll down
and go to vbo business objects
and here you can see email pop3
smtp select click on open select this
and click on open and click on
next
click on next
click on next
so when you're done with this the email
pop3 smtp will be imported
the next thing is create a new process
so select process go to create new
process
and let's name the process
we'll name the process as
email automation
click on next enter a description of
this process
if you want so that if some other user
opens the file
he should know that what is the process
about so enter the description
it's optional so we'll click on finish
and let's open this process now
the very first step is to drag and drop
and action so select action and drop it
here
open this action
so in first step we will set up the
email of the smtp
business object so we'll name it as name
this action as setup
select the business object as email pop3
smtp
and the action is configure we are
configuring it
and here we have to enter the username
password of the server
details so from where do we get the
server details
to get the server details we have to go
to the browser
go to the browser and
search as gmail server configuration
here you see you will get the all the
details here
the port number the email
so in the smtp server we'll enter the
smtp.gmail.com and the port number as
587
and in the pop3 we will enter pop
gmail.com and port number as 995
and both the servers will turn it on
to turn it on we'll write it as true
so we'll go back to the blue prism
so enter the server
pop.gmail.com enter it in the double
quotes
an smtp server enter as smtp
dot gmail.com
and the pop report number is 995
and the smtp port number is 587
and pop use ssl should turn it on to
turn it on we need to enter the value as
true
okay now we should enter the username
and password
i enter the password here for example if
i enter the password here the password
is visible
we don't want the password to be visible
the password should be encrypted
so for the password to be encrypted in
data item there is an option called
passwording data types
so go to data item
drag and drop a data item
and select the data type as password
and enter the password here here the
password will be
encrypted
and click on ok
we'll name the data item as password
similarly we will use another data item
for username
name the data item as username select
the data type as
text and give the initial value
so enter your email id
and click on ok so now we have username
and password
now go to the setup and select the
username and password
drag and drop this username
and in the password drag and drop the
password
so so the setup is done
the next step is
the next step is we want to enter the
subject and the data in the mail
right for that we need to use another
action
item drag and drop another action
name it as sending message
select the business object as email pop
sm
tp
and go to action and in the action
select the action as send message
here you need to enter the email id to
whom you want to send
so i'll enter the email id which we had
entered in the username
enter both the from and to email ids so
i'll use the same email id
since this is just for demo i'm using
the same email id
so enter the subject subject i'll enter
it as
demo and enter the body
hello
so now that we have entered the subject
and body let's
close this and now let us
now use the link and connect it
now let us click on run and check
whether we have received the email
oops there is an error we have missed
something
oh we have missed a double quote
let us save again
reset and run
so the process is completed let us go to
the email
inbox and check whether we have received
the email
so let me refresh and here we go
we have received the email
as hello and the subject is demo
so we have received the email now let us
send it with an
attachment so for that we go to the blue
prism
to go to sending message here here you
can see attachment
attachment is of the data type
collection
right so for that we need to use a
collection
item so drag and drop a collection
go to collections and
click on import select the business
object
as email and select the action
as send message and the parameter
with attachments select the attachment
and click on ok next go to initial value
in initial value click on add you can
add multiple
path here and attach how many other
attachments you want
for now we'll attach only one attachment
so you need to provide the
file path here so we'll go to the
desktop
so i have this article on desktop so
i'll attach this article in the email
so select this article
shift and right click and copy as path
copy this path go back to blue prism
and provide the path here
remove the double quotes
and click on ok
so once the collection item is completed
go back to sending message
go to collections here in the collection
select this
and click on ok
click on reset and let us run
and here you go you can see the process
is completed
so let us go to the email inbox and
check if we have received an email with
an attachment
so here we go we have received the email
with the attachment
let us open it the same email with the
subject demo
and the body as hello and with the
article which i had
attached rpa projects so i have received
the
attachment so with that we have reached
the end of this video that was all about
the demo on email automation
if you have any doubts regarding this
video you can comment in the comment
section
and our team will try to answer and like
and share it if you found it interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here